well thank you very much i first want to
thank dr. Reuben for his introduction
and I have to offer an apology because i
was late and most people here or not i
wish i had a good rationale would say i
was waiting for the people in the back
to get in the door but that's not true
i've just running late i'm sorry about
that i'll try to be cognizant of that in
the question and answer period yet if
you came in when i came in you don't get
an extra question I guess we'll do that
but we're we're grateful for so many
reasons today and especially to be here
at Carnegie Mellon and these
presentation behind me depicts both our
past and our future we're going to talk
mostly about the future Thomas Jefferson
said a long time ago that I like the
dream for the future better than the
history of the path and I think he was
right I think that's what's motivated
all of us but we'll spend a little bit
of time looking back as well but I did
want to thank dr. cause before getting
kicking us off today and getting our
program started I was met at the coming
in into the campus by dr. Brian and also
where's Davin enough tip got in the room
she's in the back she was pretty nervous
for late yep thank you for for being
with us today dr. Reuben thank you not
only for your presence here today in
your introduction but for your
remarkable leadership on some of the
issues were talking about today in your
distinguished scholarship and notoriety
on so many of the issues we confront and
I don't profess today to have all the
answers if you have better answers at
the end I hope you come up incorrectly
but so many others who are here today
from the Carnegie Mellon fam of the
Steinbrenner family are grateful for
what we're able to do in a on a campus
and in a facility like this be talking a
little bit about the ailments that in a
moment but I did want to also recognize
and thank rich Fitzgerald from County
Council who's here and we're grateful
for your presence read
the men and women organized labor
represented in different ways here Jack
Shea I thought was here at an image in
theory of Jack thank you for for being
here today with this but it's great to
be back again in Pittsburgh honor we
don't get a chance to do this very often
some people might think we'll when
you're a public official in Pennsylvania
where when you happy to be in the US
Senate you're making big big speeches
all the time it isn't true we tend to
have a lot of opportunities to speak on
the Senate floor and I have on these
topics so that will discuss today and
others as well but we don't get a chance
to come back to Pennsylvania and come to
a site and give remarks about a major
issue like this so it is rare
unfortunately it's rare but we're
grateful that Carnegie Mellon provided
has provided me this opportunity but
it's also great to be in Pittsburgh
again I won't go into a lot of stories
about about growing up in Pennsylvania
and spending as much time as I did as a
young boy in Pittsburgh and then and
coming out here on campaigns and and
coming out here in so many personal
context as I have this is the city that
saved my father's life with a heart and
liver transplant I didn't need say very
little beyond that so one for you to
understand what's in my heart when I
come to this city and I also am grateful
for the way that this city was able to
show the world in a lot of different
contexts a lot of different examples but
especially when the world saw this the
city this region is Commonwealth on
display at the g20 thank you for the
work that each and every one of you did
to make that successful across the city
and across this region at the time I
guess just prior to the the g20
President Obama called Pittsburgh quote
a bold example of how to create new jobs
and businesses while transitioning to a
21st century economy in a very short
sentence he captured
the essence of both Pittsburgh's past in
its history and heritage of hard work
and sacrifice and innovation we could
add more words to that but also in that
one sentence the president captured the
bright promise of tomorrow the bright
promise of Pittsburgh future in our
Commonwealth future I'm particularly
honored to be here at Carnegie Mellon
that we know is a school that has always
been committed to academic excellence as
well as excellence in innovation and
ingenuity and new discoveries and moving
into the future together this
institution has played a significant
role in the transformation of Pittsburgh
in the region and beyond and to be here
at the hillman Center for future
generation technologies a Leadership in
Energy and Environmental Design
so-called lead we sometimes use acronyms
in Washington and people had sometimes
desk is what they all mean for those of
you don't know I wanted to make sure
that we knew that a leed-certified
building one of the eight such buildings
on this campus I'm told we meet here
today though not just to talk about our
energy future in the wonders of
technology and discovery and innovation
that we're seeing play out here in
Pittsburgh across the region across the
country really but we also meet here at
a time of economic trauma so many
families in our Commonwealth in our
country are living through an economic
nightmare they've lost their homes or
their jobs or both and in many cases
because of those losses and others
they've lost their hopes and their
dreams we have to recognize that and be
cognizant of how difficult this economy
is for so many Americans were above ten
percent and unemployment some thought we
would get there others hoped we never
would but we have millions and millions
of people out of work in America today
in Pennsylvania it's about
a half a million people when you look at
that in terms of the unemployment rate
in our state of about eight point eight
percent and you compare it to Michigan
or some other states where we're we're
almost at half of what they're at states
that have twelve and fourteen and
fifteen percent unemployment rate
unemployment rates in a rel in a by
percentage in a relative sense we seem
better arm but when you have a half
million people out of work in a state
like ours it's hard to put that number
into any context that makes sense for so
many Americans and so many people across
our state this is a time of real
darkness but in the midst of that
darkness I believe there's no better
place to look for the light the light of
inspiration in the light of ideas no
better placed in Pittsburgh southwestern
Pennsylvania and indeed our Hulk whole
Commonwealth because there are good
things that we can report but we should
not be we should not be unmindful of the
the context of this challenge and not
unmindful of the challenges that we face
economically but unfortunately our
challenges are not simply economic
carbon pollution threatens our future
and I believe threatens human life as
well I was struck by a Time magazine
story and I should have it with me all
the time because I've often referred to
it but it's a Time magazine story from
about somewhere in 2005 that I that I
found and I'll someday I'll get the
right site but I know what I read a long
piece about global warming and the
effects of it on the world and there's
one sentence in that article that had a
profound impact upon me as a public
official but also as a Pennsylvanian and
an American and it was a very brief
summary
the challenge that this issue presents
as it relates to drug said something
like in about 35 years from about 1972
2000-2004 2005 in that 30-some your
period of time the percent of the earth
surface that had been the subject of
drought doubled in those 35 years when i
read that i'm not a scientist i'm not a
an expert on under out i'm not an expert
on a number of things that you could
number of subjects that would arise from
that kind of a statement but when i read
that i realized for almost like in a
moment that we all have in our life when
we're analyzing an issue an epiphany and
discovery and insight that we didn't
have before i realized that when you
double the amount of the earth's surface
that's been subjected to drought
horrific consequences flow from that
when you have more drought you have you
have a failure to have enough water and
irrigation to grow crops that leads to
hunger and starvation and darkness and
death that's what i derive from and it
became for me a very important moment in
this debate and unfortunately we are not
just discovering this today we've known
this for a good bit of time but
fortunately we're starting to address it
only in the last couple of years but for
decades powerful corporate interests
have kept us dependent on foreign oil
and protected corporations that have
polluted the air our children breathe in
the water they drink America's
dependence on foreign oil hurts our
economy helps our enemies helps our
enemies and puts our security at risk
instead of spending a billion dollars a
day on foreign oil we should invest that
money here
we need energy legislation that puts
America back in control back in control
and makes America more energy
independent creating millions of jobs
reducing carbon pollution and investing
in secure clean energy sources that are
made in America and work for America and
I believe that Pennsylvania can play a
key part in that future and to
understand that we need only to look at
where we've where we've been and where
we are today a 2002 book about
Pennsylvania history in in that book dr.
Brent glass the former executive
director the Pennsylvania historic
historical and museum Commission wrote
the following and I quote Pennsylvania's
central place and the Industrial
Revolution is evident in so many places
but perhaps Drake well near Titusville
is the most enduring icon of that
extraordinary period the discovery of
oil in that Pennsylvania town in 1859
and the commercial exploitation of oil
and later natural gas triggered a boom
that created tremendous wealth and
spectacular failures an abundance of
other natural resources cold timber and
iron ore coupled with the
entrepreneurial leadership in
Philadelphia Pittsburgh and several
other cities made Pennsylvania an
industrial behemoth for more than a
century the legacy of discovery and
innovation is evident in the 20th
century milestones and research and
technology for example for polio vaccine
artificial intelligence and the computer
were reached in Pennsylvania's
laboratories unquote we know that for
example the during World War one
Pennsylvania's industrial production was
unmatched absolutely unmatched in the
country and maybe the world pittsburgh
mills turned out eighty percent of all
the steel used by
I the US Army for arms and ammunition
while mines in southwestern Pennsylvania
provided 75% of the coal consumed by
munitions manufacturers during the war
so said that same history of
Pennsylvania with seismic change however
Pennsylvania has endured periods of
unprecedented job loss and population
declines manufacturing jobs and
especially steel coal and rail jobs were
impacted by dramatic drops in production
it's another quotation from this the
history quote in the Pittsburgh area as
a whole the number of Steel Workers fell
from 90,000 in 1982 44,000 in 1984 for
years the number of steel workers cut in
half in this region and the history says
this very pointedly wars have caused
less economic damage than this unquote
the same can be said of population laws
that loss has been staggering in this
state not only in southwestern
Pennsylvania but in places like my home
area of northeastern Pennsylvania just
imagine this between 1930 and 2000
basically the lifetime of my father was
born in 1932 and died in 2000 in his
lifetime major cities losing a third or
more of their population one-third of
their population in about 70 years
included the following cities Pittsburgh
altona Johnstown the key sport Newcastle
Scranton my hometown wilkes-barre and
Harrisburg among smaller cities declines
of fifty percent fifty percent or more
occurred in nanticoke shamokin in
monessen nanticoke is right down the
road for me Shamokin is not that far in
monessen is all the way out here we know
that the contraction amounted to sixty
percent sixty percent population loss in
Duquesne and Ambridge and seventy
percent population laws in Homestead
of those numbers we know or some of them
we know but it's important to put that
into context the economic devastation
that we've seen it throughout our
history throughout our state
Pennsylvania's industrial might and
substantial extraction in use of natural
resources cause significant
environmental damage at the same time so
even as we lost our industrial strength
over time we are also causing a
tremendous environmental damage and the
battle and maybe that's not the
strongest word we can use the battle to
preserve our environment was and has
been and continues to be a tough battle
for decades against very powerful
interests it was not until nineteen
fifty 1950 that state law required
communities along the Susquehanna River
to build sewage treatment plants instead
of pumping millions of gallons of raw
sewage into the river that same history
I referred to says and I quote by the
1960s pollution was causing catastrophic
fish kills and rivers we know that
sportsman in Pennsylvania are witnesses
to the degradation of our natural
environment here in Penns woods across
our state a few years ago is reported
that the ice fishing season is three
weeks shorter three weeks shorter than
it was just two decades ago and trout
fishermen fear that global warming will
reduce further the number of streams
that can provide cool waters that trout
need to survive in in 1965 not that long
ago 1965 the clean streams law was
passed and in 1971 the state
constitution was amended to reflect the
Commonwealth's commitment to preserving
God's creation here's what article
article 1 section 27 says in the
pennsylvania state constitution the
people shall have a right to clean air
pure water into the preservation of the
natural scenic historic and aesthetic
values of the environment
pennsylvania's public natural resources
are the common property of all the
people including generations yet to come
as trustees important word as trustees
of these resources the Commonwealth
shall can serve and maintain them for
the benefit of all the people that's
what our state constitution charges us
with doing as Pennsylvania's so our past
is instructive as we work to invent the
future a future and we must in which we
must rise to the challenge of climate
change and putting America back in
control of its own energy instead of
continuing our dependence on foreign
energy which hurts our economy helps our
enemies and puts our security at risk so
the message of Pennsylvania history is
clear in a number of ways but it's
certainly clear in this way as well that
old expression been there done that
we've done this before we know how to
create jobs in Pennsylvania we know how
to innovate and change we know how to
adapt so been there done that but this
time even better even better than we did
in the decades and even in the previous
century but also we need to do this in a
different way with a better
understanding of our responsibility to
future generations so the opportunity to
do it is here again and I believe the
future is now president Obama as our new
president has set us on a course to
mitigate the impacts of global warming
pollution and to make investments that
will help allow us I should say to
become exporters of clean energy in the
United States Senate Senator John Kerry
the chairman of the Foreign Relations
Committee and Senator Barbara Boxer
chairwoman of the Environment and Public
Works Committee have introduced their
climate bill Senate bill 1733 the clean
energy jobs in America Power Act that is
an effort toward bringing the
president's goal to reality
I share the president's vision for our
clean energy future at the same time I
want to make sure that whatever
solutions we reach is good for America
and for Pennsylvania we have already
begun taking steps toward our goal after
opposition by Republicans in the Senate
we enacted the kind of the Congress
enacted as part of the emergency
economic stabilization built I'm called
the tarp ill I'm using the formal name
the economics emerges the economic
stabilization bill last year we enacted
an extension of tax incentives for
businesses to invest in power generated
from the wind the Sun geothermal and
other sources of clean renewable energy
now that went by a lot of people because
it was the the so-called bailout bill
well a lot of people didn't realize that
unless we attach those tax incentives or
the extension of those tax incentives
never would happen because of Republican
opposition to that set of incentives
over at least in the time I was in the
Senate up to that point in time a year
and a half if not longer of opposition
so for those who didn't like the
emergency economic stabilization act you
should be real happy that those tax
extenders got in there for the kind of
renewable sources of energy and without
that it would be very hard to
incentivize what's been happening here
in Pennsylvania and across the country
the american recovery and reinvestment
act so the so-called stimulus bill
earlier this year includes over 80
billion dollars in investments in clean
energy to jumpstart the effort to create
clean energy jobs and also to help our
economy that bill included tax
incentives for clean energy
manufacturers and for small businesses
and families to invest in energy
efficiency and already 455 million
dollars has been set aside for
pennsylvania to promote energy
independence and another 233 million
dollars was recently announced to create
a more efficient
reliable electrical grid the system our
electrical grid system here in
Pennsylvania I work to secure
appropriation funding for clean energy
programs in infrastructure in
Pennsylvania to create jobs and save
consumers money through increased
efficiency in fiscal year 2010 I secured
nearly 1.5 million dollars for the ben
franklin technology partners clean
energy commercialization initiative
designed to advance clean alternative
energy technology development and
commercialization in fiscal year 2010 i
worked with congressman jason Altmaier
to have 1.2 million dollars appropriated
for PP PPG industries for the look for
low-cost manufacturing research and
development for solar cells in Windows
now taking advantage of the well-trained
dedicated skilled workforce an
entrepreneurial spirit that has grown
out of our industrial path and still
with us today Pennsylvania has fast
become a leader in clean and renewable
energy this includes homegrown companies
like Aztec solar power in Philadelphia
which is building solar energy systems
for residential and commercial buildings
and creating over a hundred new jobs at
a future manufacturing site in York
Pennsylvania Pennsylvania has also
attracted investment from around the
globe the Spanish wind energy company
gamesa energy established its US
headquarters in you meant in a
manufacturing facility outside of
Philadelphia more recently opening up a
windmill blade factory creating hundreds
of jobs iberdrola renewables a world
leader in clean energy technology
established its east coast headquarters
in radnor pennsylvania with more than 60
employees and build 3 wind farms in
Somerset school kill in Columbia
counties right across the middle Western
to middle of our state producing more
than 1500 construction jobs this past
summer the Pittsburgh International
Airport kicked off a project to convert
nearly one thousand five
hundred light fixtures into
energy-saving LED lighting teeming with
Appalachian lighting system of Elwood
City here in Lawrence County which is on
the cutting edge of lighting technology
and the lighting will use eighty-three
percent less energy and save county
taxpayers 158 thousand dollars per year
and just yesterday I was handed a report
that talked about southeastern
Pennsylvania but in particular was
highlighting some of the success stories
that we have in in Pennsylvania this one
example windell mechanical solutions has
found that the small components they
manufacture can be used in the design of
emergent emerging industry such as wind
turbines they have expanded their
business into this field and hope to
build their company from eight to 50
employees and so there's much too much
to celebrate but also much to celebrate
right here at CMU scientists and
engineers here are sparking clean energy
innovation CMU researchers are working
with the University of Pittsburgh Penn
State West Virginia and Virginia Tech on
ways that co2 can be safely and
economically captured transported and
sequestered in deep geological
formations through partnerships with the
auto industry CM us engineers are
helping to design more fuel-efficient
cars and working to find the best use
for biofuels the university has also
spun off a company called flextronics
that specializes in printed organic
solar technology and energy-efficient
lighting Flextronics is one of the
fastest growing companies in the city
increasing the size of its workforce
from four employees in 2002 to 65
employees in 2009 good news there the
company was named day 2009 going green
east 50 private company by always on and
one of the best places to work in
in in 2008 we'll do some other samuel
examples later just a few examples of
the enormous potential for clean energy
jobs in pennsylvania according to a
report from the Pew Charitable Trust
Pennsylvanian some people wouldn't have
said this a couple of years ago
Pennsylvania rake ranked third in the
nation and clean energy jobs how many
times you've heard that not many I'll
say it again for the press is here
Pennsylvania ranks third in the nation
for clean energy jobs not so says casey
but so says the Pew Charitable Trust
with 10,000 clean energy jobs in another
25,000 jobs in conservation and
pollution mitigation technology if we
set the right course all of this good
news and I could go to every season you
could tell me something else that's good
news but if we set the right course all
this good news can be just the beginning
a recent report released by the
Pennsylvania business leaders for a
clean energy economy suggests that clean
energy and climate legislation could
create up to seventy eight thousand jobs
in Pennsylvania while increasing real
household income by 1092 dollars and
could grow the state economy by 4.3
billion dollars so says the Pennsylvania
business leaders for a clean energy
economy the potential is enormous listen
to what John Doerr now if you know
anything about venture capital and I
know people to do I don't profess to
know but John door was still is
recognizes may be the greatest or at
least one of the great adventure
capitalist of his generation his
investments helped launch companies like
Google and Amazon we've heard of them
but John doar believes that the
opportunities for clean energy
technology are bigger than for
information technology he calls energy
the quote mother of all markets unquote
and quote perhaps the largest economic
opportunity of the 21st century unquote
so what we need is a an energy bill that
limits pollution and greenhouse gas
emissions and invest in clean energy
that is produced right here in America
it must include mandatory and achievable
limits on carbon emissions it must
include incentives for greater energy
efficiency by businesses government
government and families it must include
investments in clean renewable energy
sources like wind solar and advanced
batteries it must also include a pathway
for cleaner coal our state is ranked
fifth in coal production and coal
provides about fifty three percent of
our electricity in Pennsylvania moreover
the reliability and reasonable cost of
coal based electricity is critical to
the energy-intensive industries in our
state like steel cement pulp and paper
as well as glass and to Pennsylvania's
who must balance the household budgets
so we need to keep colon our energy mix
but in a manner that reduces pollution
through carbon capture and storage
so-called CCS technology I've worked
with senators from coal states to
recommend ways to accelerate the
demonstration and deployment of carbon
capture and storage technology I've also
introduced legislation to increase
funding for clean coral research
development and demonstration with much
of that Ardi being conducted just down
the road just down the road at the US
Department of Energy's National Energy
Technology Laboratory in South Park
Pennsylvania place I visited number of
months ago was very impressed by the
work they're doing and along with
Senator Mike Enzi a Republican of
Wyoming I introduced Senate bill 150 to
the carbon storage stewardship trust
fund Act of 2009 that will help ensure
the safety and long-term stewardship of
storing carbon dioxide and geological
formations technology has become
available to allow access to vast a vast
natural gas reserve that underlies a
large portion of our state
and it's known as everyone knows about
this now that Marcellus Shale formation
it's estimated that this formation could
supply up to a hundred years of natural
gas for the nation and with more than
one-third of Pennsylvania's electricity
coming from nuclear power plants we must
examine the role of nuclear energy in
our clean energy future here in the
Pittsburgh region nuclear energy
companies like Westinghouse
curtiss-wright flow control and hall
tech has created close to 1,600 new jobs
as we can all see from some of the
information I just reviewed Pennsylvania
has a long history of developing energy
resources and also using those resources
to spur industrial growth and create
jobs I believe a clean energy bill also
must take into account the challenge in
transitioning energy-intensive
industries to clean energy I'm
optimistic we can do this in a way that
protects workers and creates new
manufacturing jobs while the long-term
impact of clean energy will be positive
for jobs and economic opportunity we
must work to minimize the short-term
disruption an impact on workers
businesses and communities moving to a
clean energy economy will be difficult
and it will be a challenge for
industries like the steel industry in
terms of reducing pollution and
increasing energy efficiency but our
steel steel industry and our steel
workers have already begun to meet that
challenge for example us steel's Mon
Valley works that plant recently
identified an opportunity to capture
coke oven gas and use it as a fuel for a
blast furnace reducing emissions and
saving the company millions of dollars a
year towns and communities throughout
the state depend upon good-paying jobs
created by our steel industry and by
pulp and paper mills limestone kilns of
petroleum refineries glass factories and
chemical plants I'm working in the
Senate to ensure that these industries
have sufficient time to make the
transition by
providing them adequate emission
allowances I'm also working to put in
place provisions to protect against the
loss of jobs and markets to countries
that do not that do not comply with
international agreements to reduce
greenhouse gases we must have strategies
in place right now to build a bridge for
our workers in our communities as we
move to a clean energy economy I
recently introduced Senate bill 2742 the
American worker and community assistance
act this legislation will help workers
affected by pollution reduction
legislation the bill provides job
training assistance wage replacement and
health benefits to workers in
energy-intensive industries the bill
also enables community not just
individuals but communities to obtain
grants to develop comprehensive
strategic plans for community
redevelopment economic adjustment
diversification of employment
opportunities environmental remediation
projects and public infrastructure
construction projects if we craft the
right energy bill we can take control of
our nation's economic energy and our
nation's security while mitigating the
impact on our workers and our businesses
and we have little choice but to do so
the threat of climate change to our
national security is real enough that we
now know that our government is
currently assessing the readiness of our
military to protect us and keep the
peace should global warming continue
unchecked as the chairman of the Foreign
Relations Subcommittee on Near Eastern
and South and Central Asian affairs
which includes all the Middle East
Pakistan Afghanistan India Iran Iraq and
I won't mention all the countries but
I'm having to be chairman of that
subcommittee and I know that the
scarcity of water in that region of the
region meaning particularly Pakistan but
also India and Afghanistan as well that
that water scarcity is
major major challenge these countries
greatly depend upon the Indus River that
is fed by the Himalayan glacier to
supply their drinking water and the
water they need for agriculture and
Industry global warming is causing that
glacier to melt and disappear once the
glacier is gone the Indus River is
expected to lose thirty to forty percent
of its water flow Pakistan especially
but also Afghanistan are already
water-stressed countries that rely
heavily on the Indus River I don't think
I have to explain to anybody the
national security implications in this
already unstable region of the world in
terms of not having enough drinking
water or water to grow food nor do I
need to explain to anyone the risk that
countries the risk in that continues I
should say and relying upon unstable
countries and regimes for foreign oil in
action will also threaten our economic
security and our competitiveness around
the world already China leads the world
unfortunately it leads the world in wind
turbine production using technologies
that were developed right here in
America so we developed the technology
and now they're making the product that
we need we've also developed that this
country also developed the first solar
energy technologies which of Japan China
and Germany are now moving ahead in
manufacturing solar panels according to
John Doerr I've spoke of earlier only
six of the top 30 countries in solar
wind and advanced batteries are American
firms just six of the top thirty
countries companies they should say if
we allow this to continue we will simply
repeat past mistakes and sacrifice our
best chance our best chance to keep
American jobs here and to create new
industries here I believe that by
choosing the right path America will
regain control and reclaim its
competitive edge restore its energy
independence and create a new economic
engine that will drive our econ
me through the 21st century we need not
look any further than Pittsburgh for a
shining example of how an economy can
transform itself I believe we should not
and must not pick winners and losers in
this type of energy as we pursue efforts
to reduce pollution renewable energy
energy efficiency clean coal nuclear and
national natural gas all have an
important role to play and shifting to a
low lower carbon economy we have the
opportunity to make pollution reduction
work for American communities and
workers we have the opportunity to build
a strong bridge to energy and national
security we have the opportunity to get
control back to get our control back of
the American economy our security and
our energy future but it's time that the
Congress moves forward with responsible
legislation that will reduce carbon
pollution and invest in clean energy
technology to expand our nation's
manufacturing and industrial base and
create a new generation of job
opportunities and it's also time also
time that Pennsylvania a place where the
skill of our workers in the ingenuity
and innovation of our new clean energy
businesses will help lead America's Next
great economic revolution I believe all
of this all of this is a challenge
worthy of a great Commonwealth and a
great nation thank you very much